hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well perhaps one of the most famous and
often cited passages from Emanuel kant's
short work the proma to any future
metaphysics has to do with his
relationship to David Hume and it reads
like this I openly confess that my
remembering or recalling David Hume was
the very thing which many years ago
first interrupted my dogmatic Slumber
and gave my investigations in the field
of speculative philosophy a quite new
New Direction a new R right and actually
quite is a bit of an understatement
there an entirely New Direction you know
so David Hume is responsible for Kant
leaving this soporific State what does
he mean by a dogmatic Slumber so
dogmatic meaning committed to a
particular
philosophical system that remain rather
unquestioned David Hume comes along Kant
encounters his works and is like oh
wow this shakes things up you know to
use one of those tropes that people love
today this changes everything right so
he's having one of those sorts of
moments and so we could say okay well
what is hume's contribution here how did
Hume jar Emmanuel Kant out of this
complacent
see this sleepiness this SCH right in
German and so he's going to tell us he's
quite clear about this he says Hume
started mainly from a single but
important concept be Griff in
metaphysics namely that of the
connection between cause and effect
uraka the thing that you know lies
behind that that uh is prior you could
say and vung the thing that that comes
to be from the cause and if you want to
see Hume deconstructing this well you
can look at the treaties uh you know the
early work or you can look at which more
people typically do the um you know
inquiry concerning human understanding
and there it's very very well
articulated at Great length and Hume
goes into considerable depth in both of
those works
so Hume is investigating cause and
effect and you know as as Kant is going
to point out this not only has to do
with cause and effect but also
derivative Concepts like force or action
things that play a role in The Natural
Sciences which are going to be talked
about quite a bit later on in this work
and so he says uh Hume challenged reason
which pretends to have given birth to
this concept
of herself to answer him by what right
she thinks anything could be so
constituted that if that thing be
posited something else must necessarily
be posited this is the meaning of cause
so cause and effect you've got a
constant conjunction or connection as
Hume would say so there's this relation
where if you get the cause then the
effect necessarily follows and is
produced and this is the basis of lots
and lots of reasoning particularly
metaphysical reasoning now can
reason actually derived this by itself
previous
metaphysicians said yes they actually
said well you can know a lot about a
cause by looking at its effects in fact
that there has to be a cause and what
happens in the effect some would say is
derived from the Cause right so this is
a staple of previous
metaphysics then he goes on and uh Kant
says that Hume demonstrated irrefutably
it was entirely impossible for reason to
think a priori so without any reference
to experience and by means of
Concepts be Griffin right such a
combination as involves necessity and
that is part of the notion of cause as
well so if we're not getting our our
understanding our notion our concept of
cause from reason developing it on its
own without reference to experience then
where is it coming from and so uh Hume
according to is going to um you
know infer that reason was deluded with
reference to this concept it reason
believes this concept cause and effect
to be one of her children to be
something that reason has itself
produced when in reality something else
has happened it's actually a bastard of
imagination now what is a bastard we
often use that term today to mean
somebody who's a jerk in this context in
that time it means an illegitimate child
so reason has been cuckolded you could
say by imagination right imagination
produced this thing and snuck it into
reason's Nest you know house and said
this is this is your kid right reason
was like oh okay sounds good now not
only is it a bastard child of
imagination that bastard child wasn't
even impregnated by reason it was
impregnated by experience and this is a
very striking analogy but what is Kant
really getting at here he says that um
it
subsumed certain representations under
the law of Association so the law of
Association Hume develops this in the
treaties develops it further in the
inquiry right and the the associations
are that we put these things together
that either resemble each other or are
contiguous or are in the relationship of
constant conjunction cause and effect
right or at least have probability to
them where we see it 99 times out of 100
something like that and the law of
Association is a psychological law Hume
doesn't actually call this a law this is
more consan than than humean this this
interpretation but the idea is that we
cannot help but associate these things
with each other and we do so on the
basis of experience and Kant is going to
invoke a term that Hume makes a lot out
of custom so we develop these Customs
these habits of associating certain
things with each other like you know I
poke myself in the eye it hurts I learn
don't poke myself in the eye if I want
to figure out whether it hurts some more
I can poke somebody else in the eye I
can poke myself in the eye and it keeps
on hurting and you know at a certain
point probably it's not a good idea to
keep doing that because you're going to
run out of eyeball to keep Pok but be
that as it may you're establishing a
constant
conjunction but there isn't any true
metaphysical cause and effect there
there's just a bunch of things that are
kind of connected together in our
experience and so he says it mistook a
subjective necessity namely custom for
an objective necessity arising from
insight and so what is hume's conclusion
here he says reason has no power to
think such connections even in
general because their Concepts would be
purely fictitious and all these
pretended opiary cognitions nothing but
common experiences marked with a false
stamp so what is the conclusion to this
which by the way Kant doesn't agree with
um at least in
totality says this is as much to say
that there is not and cannot be any such
thing as
metaphysics at all so es Esa there is no
metaphysics kind of metaphysique right
now okay uh human or Kant actually does
think that's the case what we're calling
metaphysics in the present at the time
that he's writing is not truly
metaphysics Hume is demonstrating that
that's the case at least with cause and
effect which is an absolutely Central
concept for metaphysics but hum is going
on to say that there can cannot be any
metaphysics at all so in a way Hume is
less skeptical and more dogmatic about
that and Kant is going to say well you
know until hume's challenge has
adequately been
met we don't really have metaphysics so
Hume is doing an incredible service this
is why he awakens K from his dogmatic
Slumber in showing that all the
metaphysics up to this time that is
relying on cause and effect
is going to be
problematic and he says Humes suffered
the usual Misfortune of metaphysicians
of not being understood and he mentions
critics or you know opponents Gagner uh
the you know opposites you know uh we
could say Nemesis if you want read
Oswell Bey and lastly Priestley and he
says they always they missed the point
of the problem
and how did they do so well they turn
the question into one about the
rightness the you know rig or about the
usefulness or
indispensability of the notion of cause
and effect and Hume actually isn't
disputing that as Kant points out if you
read hume's inquiry you'll notice that
he said yeah we can't help but think
this way you know I'm just telling you
that these things about cause and effect
um although they are useful there's no
Ultimate Reality that they're based upon
right and so um K goes on and he says
whether that concept could be thought by
reason AR priori and consequently
whether it possessed an inner truth
independent of all experience implying a
more widely extended usefulness and
Universal exper uh usefulness not
limited merely to objects of experience
this was hume's problem it was a
question concerning the origin the UR of
the
concept not about whether we need the
concept not about whether it's useful to
have cause and effect but what really is
at its basis and so all of these
opponents or critics of Hume are kind of
missing the point now kod criticizes
them for another reason as well and this
is the appeal to Common
Sense which was quite common among the
uh critics of Hume and Common Sense
mention fand quite literally it means
the understanding the fand of human
beings and so it's understood to be
something that we all more or less share
in common I mean sometimes we say
somebody lacks common sense or they're
going against common sense and in his
first instance of it he calls a g
mention F so minina you know something
that we share in common with each other
a
communal uh human understanding and so
he says that they found um a more
convenient method of being defiant
without Insight the appeal to Common
Sense it is indeed a great gift of
Heaven to possess rights or as they now
call it plain common sense but this
Common Sense must be shown in Deeds well
considered in reasonable thoughts and
words not by appealing to it as an
oracle when no rational justification of
oneself can be Advanced to appeal to
Common Sense when insight and science
fail this is one of the subtle
discoveries of modern times by means of
which the most superficial Ranter can
safely enter the list with the most
thorough thinker and hold his own and
you know as a side note we see people
appealing to this today right Common
Sense interestingly it's not only been
used for a long long time but you see it
used quite a lot as a catchphrase at
least in American context by people on
the rightwing who want to think that
they possess common sense and they
deploy common sense and these liberals
or Communists or pick whoever else not
common sense not they're they're Elites
and we're the ordinary people and K
would look at that be like well first of
all how do you know that what you're
actually talking about is common sense a
lot of the stuff that you're saying is
actually nonsense this is one of the
problems with people who talk about
common sense their Common Sense may not
actually be that common let alone
Universal uh and that should make them
think oh maybe I've got things wrong
rather than trying to use it as uh a
pical tool and that's in fact what not
in political terms but in terms of
making sense of causality what what
hume's critics are doing Common Sense
solves these problems and you know Khan
points out do you think Hume doesn't
have any Common Sense he's got just as
much common sense as you guys do plus
he's also got more things at his
disposal right he says I should think
hum might fairly have laid as much claim
to common sense as Bey did and in
addition to a critical reason such as
the latter did not possess which keeps
common sense in check and prevents it
from speculating or speculations are
under discussion restrains the desire to
decide because it cannot satisfy itself
concerning its own principles by this
means alone can Common Sense remain
sound so he's saying listen appeal to
common sense if you want to but you're
basically showing yourself to be an
ignoramus by doing that not really a
philosopher let alone somebody who's
comp competent to say anything about
metaphysics so he takes hume's challenge
very very seriously and in fact as Kant
is going to tell us he is going to use
hume's
challenge against itself in a certain
way to see whether we can actually have
metaphysics he tells
us I tried first whether hume's
objection could not be put into a
general form now what do we mean by a
general form here so Hume is talking
about cause and effect in general but
he's not talking about all Concepts that
metaphysics uses just cause and effect
right so could we do this with all of
the concepts of
metaphysics and what is human's
objection well we're not getting these
from reason we are getting these from
somewhere else so says that I soon found
by actually doing this the concept of
the connection of cause and effect was
by no means the only concept by which
the understanding thinks the connection
of things a priori but rather that
metaphysics consists altogether of such
Concepts I sought to ascertain their
number when I had satisfactorily
succeeded in this by starting from a
single principle I proceeded to the
deduction of these Concepts and that is
what the first critique is actually
doing so without K shaking things up
saying ah we got a really genuine
problem here about cause and effect Kant
is saying I probably would not have been
spurred to do the work that I did that
eventually culminates in the first
critique uh taking con or taking hum's
problem so seriously that he thinks I
need to generalize this and go even
further this is part of the radical
reform and Rebirth of metaphysics that
Kant refers to a little bit earlier in
the proma here in the preface so Hume is
doing an indispensable service according
to Kant uh Kant doesn't buy into
everything that Hume is saying but he
certainly is willing to use hume's ideas
as a starting point for his own
investigations in speculative
philosophy